get ready to hile Hillary the former
first lady is officially running for
president and she can't wait to men
spread all over the ovary office Hillary
kicked off her campaign with a video
that looked a bit like a home and garden
TV reality show well we've been doing a
lot of home renovations but most
importantly we really just want to teach
our dog to good eating the trash what is
this where's the dog whisperer what was
interesting was what the video didn't
show namely the American flag I only
counted two where's your pride he'll too
good for a flag pin too good for a bald
eagle too good for fireworks but the
most troubling part of the video was the
lack of representation no not of women
not of Latinos or the gays but a group
of Americans we often forget about the
rich I guess in Hillary's America
they're just used to win elections and
then sent a drift left to run the
country from their yachts and unlike her
hubby bill the Democrats don't have an
alternative the GOP on the other hand as
a number of fine 2016 candidates who
actually stand for something Rand Paul
will secure our borders from Hillary
Clinton Ted Cruz will end energy
dependence on Hillary Clinton and Marco
Rubio will bring back jobs to America
from Hillary Clinton they're relatable
like college dropout Scott Walker who
looked better with a mullet they're
proven winners like undefeated hot dog
eating champion of New Jersey State
Governor Chris Christie but he'll if you
insist on running I have a few questions
namely where are those emails no not the
groupon Botox specials although ping me
I mean the ones about Benghazi a country
you wish didn't exist you thought it
wasn't a big deal to use your personal
email account for government matters
you're in Washington a town that runs on
transparency and dark money how can
America ever trust you again after all
the lies deception and pastel power
suits but to stop you he'll it will take
a village and about two and a half to
three billion dollars otherwise we're
all going to die
you